>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"!
MY PUBLICIST ANNOUNCED WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE HE PLANS TO RUN
AGAIN IN 2024.
WE'LL ADDRESS THAT AT SOME POINT
TOMORROW, BUT FIRST ANOTHER
CRISIS IN THE NEWS.
AFTER THE KILLINGS IN BUFFALO A
FEW WEEKS AGO YOU HEARD PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING ABOUT
RED FLAG LAWS.
THE GOVERNMENT INFORMED US COULD
AND MASS SHOOTINGS TOMORROW
SIMPLY BY TAKING THE GUNS AWAY
FROM MASS SHOOTERS BEFORE THEY
COMMIT MASS SHOOTINGS.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
IT'S SUCH AN OBVIOUS SOLUTION
THAT YOU HAD TO THINK ABOUT WHY
WE WEREN'T ALREADY DOING THAT.
WHO DOESN'T WANT TO PREVENT
MASS SHOOTINGS?
ONLY THE GUN LOBBY, EVERYBODY
ELSE CARES ABOUT CHILDREN.
AMERICANS SAY THEY WANT RED FLAG
LAWS.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
LIKE SUPPORTING BLACK LIVES
MATTER OR FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE OR GETTING THE COVID SHOT
OR STANDING WITH THE BRAVE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
RED FLAG LAWS SEEM LIKE ONE OF
THE IDEAS THAT NO DECENT PERSON
COULD POSSIBLY OPPOSE.
YOU WANT CRAZY PEOPLE TO HAVE
GUNS?
OF COURSE YOU DON'T.
WHO WOULD?
SO NATURALLY, YOU ARE FOR A
RED FLAG LAWS.
YOU MAY SOON GET RED FLAG LAWS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN IF WE DO?
TO THINGS YOU SHOULD KNOW.
FIRST, RED FLAG LAWS WILL NOT
END MASS SHOOTINGS.
BUT RED FLAG LAWS WILL END DUE
PROCESS.
DUE PROCESS IS A SIMPLE CONCEPT
BUT IT'S THE KEY TO EVERYTHING
GOOD ABOUT AMERICA.
IN OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE,
CITIZENS CANNOT BE PUNISHED
WITHOUT FIRST BEING CHARGED WITH
A CRIME.
POLITICIANS CANNOT JUST DECIDE
TO HURT YOU, THROW YOU IN
HANDCUFFS, LOFT DELL MIKE
LUCKETT AND GERALD SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE HOW YOU
THINK OR VOTE.
BEFORE THEY PUNISH YOU, THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH A FORMAL
PROCESS IN WHICH THEY DESCRIBE
WHICH SIMPLE LAW YOU BROKE AND
HOW YOU BROKE IT.
THEY HAVE TO PROVE IT.
FOR SERIOUS CRIMES WITH BIG
PENALTIES, THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO
CONVINCE A GROUP OF THE FELLOW
CITIZENS FIRST, CALLED THE GRAND
JURY.
THE GOVERNMENT MUST CONVINCE
THEM YOU DESERVE TO BE PUNISHED
OR THEY CANNOT PROCEED.
IF NONE OF THIS IS NEW, IT'S THE
WAY WE'VE DONE THINGS IN AMERICA
FOR MORE THAN 200 YEARS AND IT'S
EXACTLY WHY WE HAVE AND HAVE
ALWAYS HAD THE FAIREST JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
PEOPLE MOVE TO THE COUNTRY FROM
ALL OVER THE GLOBE TO BENEFIT
FROM IT.
BUT THE RED FLAG LAWS WILL END
THIS.
UNDER RED FLAG LAWS, THE
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T HAVE TO PROVE
YOU DID ANYTHING WRONG IN ORDER
TO STRIP YOU OF THE MOST BASIC
RIGHTS.
ALL REQUIRED TO PUNISH YOU IS A
COMPLAINT AND POSSIBLY EVEN AN
ANONYMOUS COMPLAINT WHEN
SOMEBODY SAYS YOU SEEM
DANGEROUS.
THAT COMPLAINT DOESN'T COME FROM
A GRAND JURY, IT CAN COME FROM
ANYONE INCLUDING 70 WHO HATES
YOU OR SIMPLY DOESN'T LIKE YOUR
POLITICS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE THE
JURY WILL NEVER SEE IT.
ON THE BASIS OF THE UNPROVEN
COMPLAINT YOU LOSE YOUR FREEDOM
AND ABILITY TO DEFEND YOURSELF
AND YOUR FAMILY.
HOW COULD THAT POSSIBLY HAPPEN
IN THIS COUNTRY?
THE SUPREME COURT SAID
UNEQUIVOCALLY SAID IT CAN'T
HAPPEN HERE.
IT RULED IN A CASE.
SEEING THE PERSONAL FIREARMS OF
A 68-YEAR-OLD MAN WHOSE WIFE
CALLED IN A COMPLAINT AFTER THEY
HAD AN ARGUMENT.
THE MAN COMMITTED NO CRIME AND
BEEN CONVICTED OF A CRIME AND
JUDGED BY DOCTORS TO BE SANE.
GET THE AUTHORITIES TOOK AWAY
HIS GUNS ANYWAY.
HE SUED UNDER THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT AND THE CASE WENT TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
THE RESULT WAS NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THE SUPREME COURT SIDED WITH THE
GUN OWNER IN THE CASE IN A RARE
9-0 DECISION.
IF THAT MEANS THAT EVERY
JUSTICE, LIBERAL AND
CONSERVATIVE AGREED AUTHORITIES
CANNOT JUST SEIZE YOUR PROPERTY
OR THROW YOU IN JAIL IF THEY
DON'T LIKE THE WAY YOU LOOK.
RED FLAG LAWS ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
PERIOD.
IF WE DON'T HAVE TO GUESS ABOUT
THAT.
YET BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
PUSHING IN ANY WAY WHY?
BECAUSE THEY DON'T CARE.
HOW IS JOE BIDEN ABLE TO IGNORE
SUPREME COURT DECISION FROM LAST
YEAR?
SIMPLE.
HE DECLARES AN EMERGENCY AND
DOES WHAT HE WANTS.
HE'S DONE IT BEFORE.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE DID THE SAME
THING WITH THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM AND VACCINE MANDATES
LAST YEAR.
IT'S AN EMERGENCY, WE DON'T HAVE
TIME FOR A NEW PROCESS.
YOU CAN SEE WHY DEMOCRATS LOVE
EMERGENCIES, NOTHING GIVES THEM
MORE POWER MORE QUICKLY.
THEY DECLARED THE ATROCITIES IN
UVALDE AND BUFFALO AN EMERGENCY,
UNLIKE THE DAILY MASS SHOOTINGS
IN BALTIMORE IN CHICAGO, CITIES
THEY RUN AND KILLINGS THEREFORE
THE IGNORE.
ON THE BASE OF THE EMERGENCY,
THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH GUN
CONFISCATION.
THE WHITE HOUSE NOW WANTS
CONGRESS TO PASS A LAW PAYING
STATES TO ENACT RED FLAG LAWS.
HERE'S THE AMAZING PART.
AT LEAST TEN REPUBLICAN SENATORS
ARE BACKING THE EFFORT FROM
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
VIRTUALLY THAT'S GUARANTEED TO
PASS.
WHAT'S THE REASONING?
HERE'S ONE OF THE SENATORS.
JOHN KORMAN OF TEXAS.
>> YOU HAVE COLLEAGUES ON ANY
OTHER CHAMBER WHO ARE ALREADY
COMING OUT AGAINST THIS BEFORE
YOU PUT OUT A PROPOSAL.
>> NOT SURPRISED.
SOME PEOPLE WILL NOT WANT TO
TOUCH THIS WITH A 10-FOOT POLE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POLITICS OF IT.
BUT THIS IS A TIME WHERE
HOPEFULLY WE CAN TRANSCEND THAT
PERSONAL POLITICAL AND DO WHAT
WE THINK WILL SAVE LIVES.
TO ME, THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL.
WE CAN DO SOMETHING SENSIBLE
BECAUSE THAT DOES NOT UNDERMINE
THE RIGHTS OF LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS UNDER THE CONSTITUTION
TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS.
OF >> Tucker: TWO THINGS TO
NOTICE ABOUT THE SOUND BITE
WHICH IS SO REVEALING.
THE FIRST IS THE USE OF THE TERM
SENSIBLE.
THAT'S A DEMOCRATIC TALKING
POINT APPROVED BY THE DNC,
SENSIBLE GUN SAFETY REGULATION.
IF YOU HAVE JOHN CORNYN TAKING
NANCY PELOSI'S LANGUAGE.
DOING IT ON PURPOSE.
YOU HEAR HIM DESCRIBE ANYBODY
WHO DISAGREES WITH HIM, WHY
WOULD YOU DISAGREE?
ACCORDING TO JOHN CORNYN,
ANYBODY IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POLITICS OF RED FLAG LAWS.
NOT THE WISDOM OF RED FLAG LAWS,
NOT WHETHER OR NOT RED FLAG LAWS
OR CONSTITUTIONAL COME UP AT
GRUBBY POLITICS.
IN OTHER WORDS SAYS JOHN CORNYN,
EVERYBODY WHO DISAGREES WITH ME
IS ALONE AND UNETHICAL.
IF YOU ARE NOT USED TO EAT
HEARING DEMAGOGUERY LIKE THAT,
YOU SHOULD KNOW JOHN
ROB PORTMAN OF OHIO,
NORTH CAROLINA, MITT ROMNEY OF
COURSE IF YOU TALK ON THE
BILL CASSIDY OF LOUISIANA,
SUSAN COLLINS.
LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA, ON BOARD FOR ANY
BAD IDEA, AND PAT TOOMEY OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
INTERESTING TO SEE
LINDSEY GRAHAM ON BOARD, THE
PERSON WHO ENCOURAGED CAPITOL
POLICE TO SHOOT MORE TRUMP
VOTERS WHO HAS NO PROBLEM WITH
VIOLENCE.
NO, ALL THE SENATORS NAMES THAT
WE JUST READ, HAVE THE BACKING
OF THE TOP REPUBLICAN
MITCH McCONNELL.
WHAT ARE THEY BACKING WHEN THEY
BACK RED FLAG LAWS?
WE CAN TAKE FLORIDA'S EXPERIENCE
AS AN EXAMPLE.
IN FLORIDA, THE POLICE CAN SEIZE
GUNS FROM PEOPLE OPPOSING
"SIGNIFICANT DANGER BASED ON ANY
RELEVANT EVIDENCE."
THAT'S IT.
ANY RELEVANT EVIDENCE.
IT RAISES SOME OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS.
MOST OBVIOUS IS IF YOU CAN SEIZE
PEOPLE'S GUNS BEFORE THEY
COMMITTED A CRIME, WHY CAN'T YOU
IMPRISON THEM WITHOUT PROVING
THEY COMMITTED A CRIME?
IF YOU CAN TAKE THE GUNS, WHY
CAN'T YOU TAKE THEIR HOPES?
EMPTY THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS.
SOME PARANOID?
THAT JUST HAPPENED IN CANADA.
WHAT'S STOPPING IT FROM
HAPPENING AT HERE?
WE KNOW AUTHORITIES ARE ABUSING
THE RED FLAG LAWS IN THE BOOKS.
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW, SHE SAID
CLIENTS WERE ABLE TO HIRE
LAWYERS WHO HAVE VASTLY HIGHER
ODDS OF GETTING THE FIRE ARMS
BACK TO THE GOVERNMENT.
OF COURSE.
IT LAWS LIKE THIS ALWAYS
PENALIZE THE WEAKEST.
SHE SAID COURTS ARE TAKING A
BETTER SAFE THAN SORRY APPROACH
TO AVOID A POLITICAL BLOWBACK.
IF POLICE ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THAT.
IF COURT RECORDS SHOW COPS IN
FLORIDA SHOW UP TO THE HOMES OF
CITIZENS AND PREVENT THEM WITH
STIPULATIONS.
IF YOU AGREE IN WRITING TO
SURRENDER YOUR FIREARMS, YOU
HAVE A CHANCE OF GETTING THEM
BACK AFTER A YEAR.
AS IT HAPPENS, THAT'S A PRETTY
TEMPTING OFFER IF YOU HAVE ARMED
PEOPLE IN YOUR LIVING ROOM.
BUT IT IS AND IT REMAINS, WE
DON'T HAVE TO GUESS ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THE SUPREME COURT JUST
RULED ON IT.
IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT'S FOR SEVERAL REASONS, A
CLEAR VIOLATION OF THE SEARCH
AND SEIZURE PROHIBITION.
EVEN PEOPLE WHO WROTE TO THE
CURRENT RED FLAG LAWS ADMIT
THAT.
IN NEW YORK, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COSPONSOR OF THE RED FLAG LAWS
SAID IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
YOU HAVE PLACES WHERE YOU HAVE
ONE FILE AND THE OTHER WHERE
THERE'S 38.
FOR UNCONSTITUTIONAL SEARCH AND
SEIZURE.
ARMED AUTHORITIES SHOWING UP AT
SOME OF THESE HOME AND TAKING
THEIR PERSONAL PROPERTY.
LOOK AT THIS.
THIS IS A GOD, THE VERY SAME
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO HAD --
WITH A CHINESE SPY DEMANDING
THAT COPS DISARM BEN SHAPIRO
BECAUSE BEN SHAPIRO SAYS THINGS
THE GOVERNMENT DISAGREES WITH.
PLEASE TELL ME THIS LUNATIC
DOESN'T OWN A GUN.
REASON NUMBER 1,578 AMERICA
NEEDS RED FLAG LAWS.
IF ERIC SWALWELL WROTE THAT.
NOW, WHAT WOULD QUALIFY AS A
TRIGGER FOR GUN SEIZURE UNDER
THE RED FLAG LAWS THAT HE
SUPPORTS AND REPUBLICAN SUPPORT?
HERE'S THE VIDEO THAT
BEN SHAPIRO MADE THAT
ERIC SWALWELL THINKS QUALIFIES
HIM FOR RED FLAG LAWS.
WATCH.
>> IF YOU COME TO TELL ME YOU'RE
GOING TO INDOCTRINATE MY KIDS
AND THEN I CAN'T PULL MY KID OUT
OF THE SCHOOL AND SEND MY KID TO
A SCHOOL THAT I WANT THEM TO, I
CAN'T GO TO THE CHURCH OR
SYNAGOGUE I WANT TO.
IF YOU MAKE THAT NATIONAL
POLICY, BUT NATIONAL POLICY.
IF PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO STAND
FOR THAT.
I'VE GOT TWO CHOICES.
LEAVE THE COUNTRY EARLY.
CHOOSE TO PICK UP A GUN.
ONLY THE CHOICES YOU HAVE LEFT.
HOW CAN YOU SAY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THE CONSTITUTION WAS CREATED IN
ORDER TO PROTECT.
>> Tucker: WRITES PREEXIST
GOVERNMENT.
THE GOVERNING DOCUMENTS MAKE
THAT POINT.
ON THE BASIS OF THE FACT OF
QUOTING THE FOUNDING DOCUMENTS
OF THE COUNTRY.
ERIC SWALWELL SAYS THE POLICE
SHOULD SHOW UP AT BEN SHAPIRO'S
HOUSE AND TAKE THE FIREARMS
AWAY.
DOES ANYBODY BELIEVE BEN SHAPIRO
IS A VIOLENT THREAT TO ANYBODY?
NO, HE'S AN IDEOLOGICAL THREAT
AND AN IDEOLOGICAL THREAT IS THE
ONLY KIND OF THREATS PEOPLE LIKE
ERIC SWALWELL ACTUALLY CARE
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE LAWS THEY'RE PUSHING AND THE
REPUBLICANS ARE BACK.
IF THE LAWS WERE ACTUALLY
DESIGNED TO FIGHT GUN CRIME,
THEY WOULD HAVE FORCED
PROSECUTORS TO ENFORCE EXISTING
GUN LAWS AGAINST PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTING ALL THE MURDERS.
IT'S NOT BEN SHAPIRO.
LOS ANGELES AND MANY OTHER
CITIES, THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
THAT'S WHY CRIMINALS OPENLY
SUPPORT.
WATCH.
>> I TOLD YOU LAST TIME.
TRYING TO REELECT SOMEBODY ELSE.
IT'LL LEAP YOUR LIFE UP WITH
WITHOUTPAROLE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THAT'S ONE TAPE WE CAN PLAY AS
WE OFTEN DO, A VIDEO IN OUR
CITIES.
SO PEOPLE WHO ARE FAVORED BY THE
REGIME CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT.
VOTE THE RIGHT WAY, COMMIT
WHATEVER CRIMES YOU WANT.
BALTIMORE WILL HAPPEN.
AT MASS KILLINGS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS FOR DECADES AND NOBODY
WILL SAY A WORD.
BUT IF YOU'RE DISFAVORED BY THE
REGIME, NO PUNISHMENT TO STRONG
OR INFRACTION TOO SMALL.
NONE OF THE GUN LEGISLATION,
JOHN CORNYN AND THE OTHER
POMPOUS BUFFOONS ARE SIGNING
WITH NANCY PELOSI.
SUPPORT NONE OF THE LEGISLATION
WILL DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE CORE
PROBLEM WHICH IS DAs LORD
GEORGE CASS
: FAILING TO ENFORCE EXISTING
GUN LAWS.
BY THE WAY, GEORGE HIMSELF NAMED
ONE EXAMPLE IS BREAKING.
IF A WHISTLE-BLOWER HE SAID HE
WAS FIRED FOR COMPLAINING ABOUT
THE HABIT OF ILLEGALLY CARRYING
FIREARMS ABOARD AIRPLANES.
WHY HAVEN'T THE COPS RED FLAGGED
GEORGE AND DISARMED HIM?
IS ANYBODY GOING TO RED FLAG
HUNTER BIDEN WHO LIED ON A
FEDERAL DRUG FORM?
WAS AT A DRUG ADDICT CARRYING IN
ILLEGALLY OBTAINED WEAPON?
NO, OF COURSE NOT.
RED FLAG LAWS AREN'T DESIGNED TO
PUNISH THE POLITICAL LOYAL.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET SCENES LIKE
THIS IN THE WORLD.
POLICE DO NOTHING ABOUT.
WATCH.
>> [SHOUTING]
>> Tucker: SO, HEY,
JOHN CORNYN, YOUR LEGISLATION DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT?
IS ANYBODY WHO'S OKAY WITH THAT
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN DOWNTOWN
CHICAGO OR DOWNTOWN BALTIMORE,
PICK A CITY.
IF EVERY DAY OF THE WEEK, GET
BACK TO ME ABOUT THAT WITH
THE AR IN MY CLOSET.
BY THE WAY, NOT WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT YOU JUST SAW.
AT LAST YEAR HIS OFFICE MISSED
60% OF THE FELONY CASES THAT
INTO HIS OFFICE, MOST COMING TO
ABOUT GUN INFRACTIONS.
ONLY 68% OF THOSE CASES.
ANOTHER D8 IN PHILADELPHIA HAS A
SIMILAR RECORD.
LARRY KRASNER'S OFFICE DISMISSED
65% OF ALL GUN CHARGES.
DOES THAT SEEM HIGH?
IT IS, 2015 THAT FIGURE WAS 17%.
NEW IDEOLOGY?
NEW OUTCOME.
BY THE WAY, THE OUTCOME IS MORE
DEAD PEOPLE.
BUT THIS LAW DOES NOTHING ABOUT
THAT.
IT IGNORES IT COMPLETELY IN
FAVOR OF REDEFINING YOU AS A
VIOLENT THREAT AND GIVING THE
AUTHORITIES CONTROL BY
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S RIGHT TO
MARCH AT YOUR HOUSE AND DISARM
YOU.
WHAT ARE THEY IGNORING?
LET'S SEE, LAST YEAR IN
PHILADELPHIA WE SAW A RECORD SET
FOR HOMICIDES.
THIS YEAR, MORE THAN 200 PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN SHOT TO DEATH IN THE
CITY OF PHILADELPHIA WHICH IS IN
A HUGE CITY AND IT'S GETTING
SMALLER.
THE 14-YEAR-OLD BOY WAS KILLED
IN A DRIVE-BY.
A MAN WAS SHOT FIVE TIMES IN
WEST PHILADELPHIA.
ON SUNDAY NIGHT A MAN TAKING
CARE OF HIS MOTHER IN NORTH
PHILADELPHIA WAS SHOT IN THE
BACK OF THE HEAD.
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT GUN
CRIMES, GUN ATROCITIES, WE
ACTUALLY HATE VIOLENCE.
IF YOU WOULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS AND PUNISH THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE COMMITTING GUN CRIMES.
BUT NO.
THEY PREVENT YOU FROM DEFENDING
YOUR FAMILY AND BUYING AND
HOLDING GUNS.
WHY IS THAT?
WELL, WE DON'T NEED A GUESS
BECAUSE THEY'RE TELLING US.
WATCH WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THIS
GUY IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE'S MORE THAN A CRAVEN
POLITICAL ACT, HE RUNS THE DOJ.
MR. MERRICK GARLAND, THE BIGGEST
THREAT FACING THE COUNTRY TODAY.
>> THE FBI'S VIEW, THE TOP
DOMESTIC VIOLENT EXTREMIST
THREAT COMES FROM RACIALLY OR
ETHNICALLY MOTIVATED VIOLENT
EXTREMISTS SPECIFICALLY THOSE
WHO ADVOCATE FOR THE SUPERIORITY
OF THE WHITE RACE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A TOTAL LIE
ACTUALLY.
WE HAVE NUMBERS TO PROVE IT.
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S A LIE, THERE
IS NO JUSTIFICATION, RATIONALLY,
FOR WHAT MERRICK GARLAND JUST
SAID.
IT'S RIDICULOUS, OBVIOUS OR
ANYBODY LIVING IN A MAJOR CITY
KNOWS THAT.
WHY DID THEY KEEP TELLING YOU
THAT?
BECAUSE NOTHING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS DOING,
NOTHING THAT'S HAPPENING IN
CONGRESS RIGHT NOW WILL ACTUALLY
ADDRESS GUN VIOLENCE.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT,
JOHN CORNYN.
THE POINT IS TO ALLOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO BECOME MORE
POWERFUL.
IT FEELS LIKE IT TO SEND ITS
ARMED AGENTS TO RAID THE HOMES